I guess we spoil our kids a little bit
because we actually buy them costumes
when I was a kid the costumes were
usually homemade it's like my version of
the I walk to school you know uphill
both ways kind of thing my version is I
had homemade costume they've all heard
my speech about the time when I was a
kid and I wanted to be a night and
shining armor so my mom made me a a
helmet out of a cereal box wrapped in
tin foil and put that on my head and
said you're a night and Shining Armor
and then I go trick-or-treating and all
night people are like oh that's a cute
astronaut I'm holding a sword okay I get
that the helmet's not exactly it's not
exactly historically accurate but I'm an
astronaut with a sword and then later I
realized I should have just been an
astronaut with a sword because I'd be a
way cooler costume to begin with